hey everyone it's Mike from mlow and
welcome back to my channel you know it's
been a couple days since I posted a
video because I was uh very busy running
a uh trading Workshop uh for Traders
over the last three days but uh I just
finished it today and you know now I
want to get back to uh making some
content for you guys here on YouTube so
if you've been enjoying these videos be
sure to subscribe to the channel and hit
that notification Bell so you'll be
notified when I upload new videos and in
today's video um what I want to talk
about is is an an orderflow imbalance uh
strategy that you can apply to your
trading and you know
imbalances to me are one of the core
building blocks of understanding order
flow and an imbalance occurs in the
two-way auction right between the bid
and the offer when you have more
aggressive uh buying than aggressive
selling by a predetermined ratio I I use
4 to one most Traders use 4 to one or a
selling imbalance would be you know more
aggressive selling then aggressive
buying in the two-way auction Again by
the same ratio uh 4 to1
400% and you know the reason why
imbalances are important is because you
know it shows when trading is picking up
directionally now you know markets move
up and down based off of aggressive
trading right because there's a bid and
there's an offer in the market and you
know the bid is the passive buyer the
offer is the passive seller and for
someone to transact they have to be
aggressive to um either hit the bid or
lift the offer because again you know
remember if the market is just bid and
offered and nobody's being aggressive to
sell into the bid or buy the offer the
Market's not going to move so when you
have aggressive trading taking place um
it is a strong sign of potential Market
direction and you know most Traders how
they look at
imbalances is within the bar they look
at it generally they they look at it um
how was the term vertically right up and
down in the bar right selling and
balances you know stack selling and
balances is very easy to see you know
where you have three selling and
balances stacked neatly on top of each
other or stack buying balance would be
three um buy a balance a stack neatly on
top of each other you know I made a
video uh not too long ago where I
discussed multiple imbalances in a bar
like this one where you have 1 2 3 four
selling imbalances in the
bar but they're not stacked on top of
each other right if you're trading
stacked imbalances you wouldn't have a
stacked imbalance to we down here but if
you're looking at multiple imbalances in
the bar you hear this red candle has
three sorry four selling imbalances in
the bar just because they're not stacked
neatly on top of each other one on top
of the other over four price levels
doesn't mean it's not important so you
know if you get a chance uh go go back
um a few days and and find that video on
uh multiple imbalances now what I want
to talk about is
it's a different way of looking at
imbalances as opposed to vertically what
I'm going to ask you to do is look at
them horizontally what do I mean by
horizontally is over two bars two
consecutive bars okay so again normally
most Traders just look up and down in
the
bar itself but when you start looking at
it over um you know a period of time you
know especially this is a Time based
chart so it's 1 minute 2 minute cuz this
is just a a one minute Euro currency
chart so you can see you have aggressive
selling taking place here at uh 10330
and a half bar closes next Bar opens up
you still have that aggressive selling
at the same price so while in a
vertical um view of the market where you
have aggressive selling moving the
market down when you have
horizontal imbalances meaning imbalances
coming in at the same level over
consecutive bars what you have is
consistent selling right so you have it
over a period of time and in this case
it's a one minute chart so it's a period
of 2 minutes so you can see right here
there's 67 selling IM balance Red Bar
Red Bar next one 14 selling a balance
that's at the same price level okay and
is that important well it is because you
have an aggressive seller he backs off
comes back in aggressive selling at that
price and let me see if I can find a a
bullish version here for
you okay right down here at this swing
low you got 133 you've got 18 right
first bar 133 trades there 1019 second
Bar opens up trades lower the aggressive
buyers are coming in at the same price
level right over here you got some
aggressive selling after this nice move
down you know 62 Market sells off comes
back up starts training around that
level the aggressive sellers reappear
and start selling again okay now you
know if you're watching a footprint and
watching it unfold before your eyes you
can see that if you're keen on Staring
at a footprint chart all day now we do
have a tool on the orderflows trader
software it's called imbalance reload
because what you have is you have
aggressive uh Traders basically
reloading right they've like in this
case
over right here right they were
selling okay finish selling let the
market breathe a bit comes back sell
some more right Market sells off to this
swing low now the aggressive buyers are
interested because you know what hey
they they're probably thinking you know
103 12 A2 13 14 is is a good level to be
getting long so they step in they buy
133 you know helps push the market up
because you know people that watch the
order flow watch the Dome um Dom doome I
I hate that when people like correct you
and to say it you know it doesn't matter
matter it's the depth of market and
people get so caught up in the semantics
that
uh they they lose track of everything
but anyway so the aggressive buying
comes in people see that on however
they're watching order flow and they
start jumping in okay Market backs off a
little bit the aggressive buyers come in
they buy 18 this time right pushes the
market higher now the market did pull
back did pull back to this swing low
before um going much higher okay where
would you place your stop you know
behind a swing low behind you know even
behind the bars let's say you're getting
long you'd be behind the um first bar
where the first imbalance is just as so
your stop would be um below the low of
this green candle just as if you're
short here off of this imbalance reload
you know your stop would be up here it
doesn't need to be all the way up here
at the high of the day um so you got
your short here but came back with a
long shortly after doesn't quite stop
you out and then uh go back up to almost
the high of the day pretty methodically
right a nice move up but anyway um we do
have a tool on the orderflows trader
software it's called imbalance reload
let me just uh show you here okay so
again you can see imbalance trigger in
percent 400 right that's what I use
that's 4:1 and here it is right here
imbalance reload now you could choose
how you want it drawn out you know until
tested that means if the market moves
away from it it's going to draw out a
zone until it comes back to that level
or you could have it fixed a certain
amount you know just one zone size of
one which would be the two bars or you
know if you trade it if you made this
fixed it would draw it out five no
matter what even if the next bars
overlap it but we'll just keep it until
tested here
and show you
okay so right here because you can see
the market came back here here the
market came back here's another bearish
imbalance reload again where would you
stop go and just go right up in here so
you're looking at the imbalances spread
out horizontally over two bars as
opposed to like the Stacked in Balance
which comes in one bar
okay now here's that other one so you
can see this zone is being until tested
and I'm not saying that when you have a
Zone being drawn out that it's stronger
but the reason why I like to have zones
drawn out is cuz I'm very visual okay
and and sometimes whoops sorry I hit the
microphone there sometimes I'm looking
at um several markets right cuz I do
have a big screen I've got a 43 in
monitor not the curved one but you know
it's big square one so I do have
multiple charts open and when I see a
Zone being drawn out like this I know
this Market is moving right so I know I
had the aggressive selling coming in and
the market is moving in that direction
right so even even if I'm a bar late
that's fine with me because I know the
Zone's not going to be drawn out until
this bar
closes um anyway right that the Zone's
going to start to draw out because it
could trade back in there in this bar
but once this bar closes and I see that
zone starting to be drawn out it has my
attention and really that's that's what
you know as a Trader you you you want
things to draw your attention to
something happening on the chart so that
you can take advantage of it right so
even if you're getting in you know in
here two three bars a little bit later
at 27 you know there's still enough of
this move down to the 20s you can see
how the market came back up it's testing
this zone right here right this is the
Zone this is the level where the
aggressive selling was 30 uh 103 30 A2
it got back up to what 29 a half before
selling back down into the
20s so you know basically you know
that's the importance of looking at
imbalances not just
vertically in the bar up and down in the
bar but
horizontally right when you have
imbalances spread out over bars in this
case these are going to be consecutive
bars um you know I I just find it quite
strong and I know the reason behind it
is because you know I used to be an
Institutional Trader this is in the days
before we even had alos right now it's
just easy just type in you know the size
of your order that you want executed how
you want it executed and it will go do
that for you but as a big Trader right
you don't want to necessarily tip your
hand to the market you want to get
aggressive okay but problem is when you
get aggressive sometimes other Traders
see that pick up on
it and I don't say front run you because
you already executed your order but get
on the bandwagon so if you could just
come in snap up some size let the market
calm down a bit go back in be aggressive
around the same level
again then you're going to get majority
of your order
executed okay and then the market is
free to do whatever it wants okay but
the point is um watch
imbalances horizontally you know at the
same level over time as opposed to only
focusing on it vertically up and down in
the bar now I'm not saying you got to
not watch it vertically of course you
still watch it vertically but this is
just adding one
extra um way to analyze the imbalances
in the market all right orderflows
Trader does make it a lot easier for you
to see these things so if you're
interested in the software the link is
below in the description again you know
I'm the one that developed it um and and
on the program to put this all into the
work so because this is what I know that
I look for in the market and other
Traders look for in the market all right
so thanks again for watching this video
if you like it be sure to hit the like
button and if you haven't already
subscribe to that channel Channel you
know we keep growing every day and hit
the notification Bell so you get
notified whenever we post a new video
thanks everyone bye-bye